hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast professional development
cornerstone of a strong Animal Care and
Use program i'm christina joel of lab
ropes and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we're excited to bring you
this educational web seminar presented
by lab roots the leading scientific
social networking website and provider
of virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
before we begin just a couple of
important announcements this webcast is
designed to be interactive and we
encourage you to ask questions during
the event you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to get to
as many questions as we can you can
enlarge the slide window by clicking on
the screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window now if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button on the lower left I would now
like to introduce today's speakers we
have two speakers for you today dr. Anne
Turner and dr. Nicole Duffy speaking
first today will be dr. Anne Turner with
over 40 years of experience in
association management health care
administration and education dr. Anne
Turner has served her communities in
various manners she is currently the
executive director of the American
Association for laboratory animal
science a al-aas in Memphis Tennessee in
that role she is in charge of
implementing policies established by the
Board of Trustees supervising staff
managing the financial resources
administering programs and services of
the Association and overseeing the
activities of the foundation dr. Turner
earned a bachelor's degree in home
economics from the University of
Tennessee in masters of Education and
Child Development and Family Relations
from Pennsylvania State University and a
Doctor of Philosophy in community
systems planning and development also
from Penn State
dr. Turner has been a certified
association executive CAE since 1989 and
was awarded fellow status in the
American Society of Association
executives in 2006 she served on the
board of directors for ASAE and the ASAE
foundation 2011 through 2013 and
currently serves on the ASAE foundation
research committee and as a member of
the University of Tennessee Health
Sciences Center
IAC you see I will now turn it over to
dr. Turner for his further presentation
dr. Turner Thank You Christine today's
presentation will focus on the
importance of professional development
and its impact on developing and
maintaining a strong Animal Care and Use
program those who work with the animals
in the laboratory setting have one of
the most consequential assignments in
the research arena they provide the
foundation for quality research
professional development can be defined
as a combination of education experience
continuing competence professional
development and personal commitment
professional certification is an
external recognition of an individual
meeting predetermined standards
professional development programs
offered through the American Association
for laboratory animal science including
the a life learning library and the a
life certification process will be
presented as examples of professional
development resources there are many
ways to deliver training traditional
classes which are led by an informed
instructor may be the best method for
some types of education particularly in
the area of imparting knowledge to
groups learning by doing
may be best when learning skills and
techniques some people learn by reading
books and articles others learn better
by interacting with a computer or other
electronic device whether individually
or in groups flexibility and being
able to adapt to the learners needs is
critical to developing an effective
training program facilities are faced
with many challenges in developing a
world-class training program
consideration must be given to who is
trained varying levels of background
educational level experience and
understanding are represented in most
facilities animal care staff require a
wide range of knowledge and skills
encompassing husbandry animal behavior
observation skills and a myriad of
animal care and research techniques
research staff require scientific
training as well as research methodology
and animal care techniques supervisors
require advanced training and personnel
budgeting compliance management and
human resources other audience which may
require training include the
institutional care and youth committee
or the Animal Ethics Committee those
members who may need training and
regulation decision-making ethics and
research methodology while it's not
always thought of as a training
providing information about your
programs your achievements your progress
to institutional officials and
decision-makers is critical to
organization success consideration
should be given to the learning setting
because different topics are best
delivered by various methods the
objectives that the training must be
incorporated in the planning process and
documentation of training is mandatory
in many facilities and is desirable even
if not mandated another challenge is
language while English may be the
official language of science it is often
not the native tongue of the people who
work in a facility indeed there may be
multiple languages spoken and understood
each facility must examine the language
challenge for their specific site and
develop programs to ensure effective
communication and workflow
in developing an institution-wide
training program the goals for four main
audiences must be considered the
investigator training both basic and
problem-focused animal facility staff
training incorporates new staff or basic
training as well as the more seasoned
staff training perhaps your facility
only has mics and you're now adding
rabbits you would need training for a
new species training is sometimes used
as a corrective or remedial action
perhaps for non-compliance or more
frequently for lack of or improper
skills training is not the answer for
all problems and should not be viewed as
punishment the animal research field has
gotten more sophisticated with the use
of genetically engineered animals
biohazardous agents and advanced
technology trained and competent
personnel are a cornerstone of any
animal care and use program training and
laboratory animal science has developed
as the field has progressed increasingly
technicians are required to be informed
of appropriate animal husbandry
practices the characteristics of a
variety of laboratory animal species and
the use of modern technology because
centenary technicians are widely
recognized as valuable personnel for
animal research training programs for
veterinary technicians throughout the
United States often include laboratory
animal science courses in their
curriculum institutions have the
responsibility for providing animal care
and veterinary technicians appropriate
training on topics of regulations and
ethics species specific biology and
husbandry procedures of animal use
animal welfare in research facility
equipment operations and monitoring and
occupational health and safety equipment
and practices
education and training is primary to the
American Association for laboratory
animal science as reflected in the core
values statement for the organization
our programs and services are dedicated
to building and disseminating knowledge
to those who work in the field of
laboratory animal science the American
Association for laboratory animal
science and I refer that is a less from
now on out contributes to the
professional education of personnel in
the laboratory animal field as a way to
advance the humane and responsible care
of the use of laboratory animals a life
has over 40 years of experience in
education certification and continuing
education of laboratory animal
technicians and managers a lass offers a
certification program for technicians
and one for facility managers the range
of educational resources provided by a
less prepares individuals to work with
laboratory animals and supports the
professional development of technical
and managerial personnel a lab serves
all personnel in annual animal research
some of our certification research
sources we offer them both in print and
some online and conferences are central
to a lacist mission there are two areas
of professional certification three
levels of certification for technicians
and a certification program for managers
the a last technician certification
program sets professional standards for
the advancement of laboratory animal
care the program was developed to
recognize professional achievement and
provide an endorsement of a technicians
competence in laboratory animal science
a liar solvers Technician Certification
at three levels the assistant laboratory
animal technician which is basically for
people entering
to feel the new hires the first time
people the laboratory animal technician
is for the more advanced the people have
been working in the field for a period
of time and the laboratory animal
technologist is the highest level of
technician certification and focuses on
people that are providing more of the
techniques what content areas are
covered by the technician exams they are
divided into two principles area of
work-related responsibility animal
husbandry and Health and Welfare and
facility management the specific
percentages for each area vary depending
on the level of the exam for example the
L a TG divides the exam evenly between
the two areas while the ala t-- exam is
predominantly animal husbandry health
and welfare more information is listed
in the technician certification handbook
and on the a last website and then we
get to a question of why would you
certify why is certification important a
line certifications give you present and
future employers the confidence that you
are competent in the lab animal field
certification is helpful as a criterion
and performance evaluations and
promotions certification builds
confidence that you are recognized and
you are knowledgeable about your jobs
the process of pursuing your
certification helps you evaluate your
strengths and your weaknesses and it
enhances career satisfaction and as part
of professional as well as personal
development and import into all of it we
do have statistics that bear out it
increases your salary potential once
you're certified that's what the R
stands for the R in front of the
certification level the nose
continuing competence the exams denote
the meeting standards at the time of
certification and the R means that you
have kept up with readings with
conferences with education and
professional development and continuing
education and here are some resources
these resources are offered by a less to
keep the certification standards current
a job analysis of each level of
technician certification is conducted
every five years based on information
gained through that job analysis and the
research that is inherent in that job
analysis certification resources are
updated and the examinations are revised
every five years they keep current with
the newest knowledge in the field and
they're all done in tandem
now why was C mark created why should a
manager become certified the c-more
certification gives you present and
future gives your present and future
employers the confidence that you are
competent in the lab animal field
certification is helpful as a criterion
and performance evaluation is build
confidence as we said before in the
knowledge about your job and
particularly the senior was created
because companies were looking for
credentialed managers many of the people
within the lab animal science start out
as technicians and have backgrounds in
animal care animal husbandry animal
welfare and they needed credentialed
managers to put that layer of management
knowledge and management skills on top
of their knowledge about the animal care
site now the c-more program is a
combination of four exams three exams
through the Institute of certified
professional managers or a demonstration
of skills through alternative means
and the fourth exam is called the animal
resources exam if you take the I CPM
exams you must contact I CPM which is
the Institute for certified professional
managers fill out their application and
pay their fees then they allow you to
take any of the three exams at your own
pace and in any order but it must be
completed within a 15 month period the
animal resources exam is administered by
ALS and that carries a separate process
so we combine specific information about
animal resources managing an animal lab
with general management skills in
addition to certification resources a
lass produces a wide variety of general
resources such as books reference books
DVDs posters recording study aids and
our foundation produces a lot of
materials and public outreach to help
you deal with your community and help
you tell people what you do now the
webinars that's one of the newest
programs these programs feature experts
on diverse topics and are good for
different audiences there are 10 of them
offered annually we usually take
Christmas off and we usually take the
meeting the month that our national
meeting is offers we do not offer
webinars during that month they the
webinars are offered worldwide group
training it's an excellent group
training opportunity because you can
have as many people at the local site as
you want the fees and signup process is
by site and here's some of the webinars
the webinars we had in 2016 you can see
it's variety of topics and it shows the
diversity of the programs the webinar is
a very cost effective it's one hundred
and fifty dollars for the general fee
and then a life member get get
discounted fee of $99 and that's per
site and you can have as many people as
you want the topics are voice of one was
how you talk to people about animal
research there was some on security
there's some on Mouse colony management
there's some on euthanasia there's some
highly scientific methodology oriented
webinars and some that are geared more
toward public outreach and toward animal
welfare now a less is perhaps best known
for its national meeting
it's the largest gathering of lab animal
professionals in the world
this year's meeting is in October and
it's in Austin Texas the program
features large keynote sessions and
lectures special topic lectures
workshops seminars there's over 200 for
you to choose from and you can match the
learning which suits your needs best
plus you need thousands of folks in all
of the world and you have ample
networking opportunities the tradeshow
is the largest in the field and features
approximately 300 exhibitors so don't
plan to fit in one afternoon you're
going to have to allow time for the
tradeshow another hallmark face to face
educational opportunity is the Institute
for laboratory animal management which
has held over two years that's one week
in successive years and is held in
Memphis Tennessee this intended program
in management lays the foundation for
lifetime learning through the iLab
alumni network more detailed information
about these programs can be found on the
ALS website now it's time to turn it
over to dr. Nicole Duffy but I think we
go back to Kristine first yes that is
- thank you so much dr. Turner for your
presentation and our next speaker yes is
dr. Nicole stuffy dr. Nicole zelphia is
the director of education and scientific
affairs for the American Association for
laboratory animal science she leads the
AAAS learning library development team
for the online learning platform and
courses in laboratory animal science she
oversees and contributes to print and
digital publications of AAAS educational
resources she directs the grants for
laboratory animal science programs dr.
Duffy is a former president of the
laboratory animal welfare training
exchange la wte
I would like to turn this now over to
dr. Duffy dr. Duffy
Thank You Kristina well welcome I'll
start with an overview of the ælis
training library which we call you all
then I'll conclude with a brief tour the
always watched 14 years ago in 2003 it
has grown to offer over 200 courses and
I don't think we'll ever be done course
development is an ongoing process so
this number will continue to grow
this year in the future and I think over
our lifetime also ongoing is the review
and updates of our courses this takes
place on a three-year cycle and as
needed in between times you also
continues to grow with another
organization that uses it 350 now
subscribe to the all we have a quarter
million users and we are approaching to
me a certificate awarded many
institutions subscribed to the all for
compliance training enamel research so
investigators are our largest audience
our next largest is animal care
technicians for training and laboratory
Amaziah
and preparing for Technician
Certification I cook memories trainers
and other personnel usually all as well
for researchers the top courses are
working - aya cooks and any of the
series of introduction to a species for
the more advanced working with a species
course and every
examples are aseptic technique for rosin
surgery inhalation anesthesia for
rodents and pain management and there's
so many there are also a series of
courses on bioimaging biosafety and
transgenics the transgenics courses are
our newest library five courses have
been completed and we're very excited to
be launching the remaining four by
summer for a total of nine like to buy a
safety program completing the
transgenics courses will confirm
overarching program certificate psychic
members use courses like essentials for
I could members post approval monitoring
and semiannual facility inspection as
well as on federal regulations and
guidelines species specific courses are
especially helpful for community members
or other other icuk members who may not
have that animal expertise but need to
inspect facilities for example where
these animals are housed there are also
biosecurity and ethics courses that are
helpful as well the all offers a wide
range of training for animal care staff
from preparing for Technician
Certification
learning about repertory mandates to
continuing education technicians can
earn CEUs to maintain their registry
status with a less some courses are
aimed as resources for trainers and a
few examples are shown here furthermore
trainers typically assign courses to
staff as perhaps prerequisites for
before attending the scheduled hands-on
by methodology session or receiving
protocol approval there are four types
of descriptions on you all three of them
of groups institution ranch global
partner institutions have the most
authorities because the employment
relationship among staff branches and
local partners have many of the same
functionality as you institutions for
without the employment relationship the
transcript data are held confidential
all three groups have management tools
and roles for group administrators to
manage access by personnel finally
individuals
and subscribe to the all themselves for
full access to courses exams and
transcript documentation but also
without a paid subscription people can
enroll any all and there in that case
they are limited to the free courses
only which are actually quite
substantial and number and the benefits
of a group subscription include
designating personnel to serve
administrator roles for the group you
know each group has a primary group
coordinator one person who is in charge
of the group but the other roles can be
filled by as many personnel as needed to
satisfy the needs of managing the group
so there can be secondary coordinators
and these manage personnel as well as
view data records and they can set up
training plans which we'll talk about
later monitors can view records but they
can't manage users authors they're given
roles to review or edit courses for the
group custom courses can be created or
adapted from an a last course and these
are restricted for use within the group
only training plans allow a group
administrator to efficiently assign a
batch of courses to one or more users in
one stroke and I'll demo that later
institutions have transcript reports are
verifying compliance these can be
downloaded manually or automatically a
lass reports can be uploaded into an
institutions on learning management
system and I mentioned that courses can
be customized for institution that means
that a group can adapt an existing AOS
course for its own use or Korean so for
scratch from scratch you all includes an
option system that makes this easy and
an institutional group can have up to 15
courses and that are custom at no charge
and up to 50 for an annual fee the types
of data reports that are available
depend on the type of group all groups
have rosters and report called tracks
and courses tracks are simply a menu of
courses that a group can create for its
users to guide them to particular
courses
institutional groups can download
reports for use a transcript data and
training assignments these reports can
be comprehensive over the group or they
can be segmented to a subset of data the
latest platform of you all was launched
in late 2016 and this is a major upgrade
to a faster system for the responsive
web design the navigation of tools a
highly streamlined and especially useful
for managing a group password security
was also upgraded by removing the
passwords review of everyone
coordinators even a lab staff now users
must reset their password via a link
that is emailed to them so let's take a
short tour we'll just take a quick view
as a group coordinator and of course an
exam we've used some sample transcript
data so what I'll do is I'll begin the
open desktop share to screen area and
then ahead and make that happen let's
see here I think we should have it now
and I believe that we are now sharing
the screen I think you should be able to
see this so what we have here is the in
my browser the landing page for the Avis
Learning Library I'll go ahead and sign
in and now I'm at the dashboard I'm
signed in in what I call a sandbox group
it's a test group and all the data here
are demo there's no records for any one
individual
I am the group coordinator this is my
caps my cans photo and before I show
very much to you let's start with a Help
Center I think it's a great place to
start here we have four topic areas
sections that have articles about using
you all in general managing a group
managing your account and working with
custom courses at the bottom I have
three recorded videos on how to use the
all the first one is less than ten
minutes long
aimed at anyone using the site so it
Orient's you to take in a course look at
your transcript your profile plan things
like that the second one which is group
management video is about how to manage
a group and it's about an hour and 20
minutes and the third one to the right
is a little bit under an hour and that's
we're working with custom courses so you
have a lot of tools used at your
disposal on how to learn how to use the
site but of course we still encourage
people to call us and let us help them
get oriented so if you had for example
on a search terms you might put in
something like the seat which is the
access that everybody uses to enter
course and exams and get documentation
of their of their training activity you
can click search and it'll guide you to
a link of that article in one of those
four sections so let's go back to group
coordinator and take a look at the
console and this is really where most
that work is done a core group
coordinator now before we get into the
details of this we might ask the basics
so how do we add members to our group
and there's four ways we can add a
member right here and in one person at a
time we could use the auto-generated
username or supply a different username
and fill out the rest of the information
and assign or not a sign of things based
on whether it's clicked and then click
Submit we can also upload a spreadsheet
of people after I download a template
open up the spreadsheet and then I could
fill in as many people as I wanted for
some information and then go ahead save
it to my computer and then upload it
when I'm ready to do so a third way is
to allow people to enroll themselves but
associate themselves with your group and
that's through what we call the access
code we go to the group profile and here
is this code that's under control of me
as the
and coordinator and I can change us at
any time and thereby expire old versions
of this exit code and and I would
distribute this to people that I want to
enroll in the group and I have some
control to about whether or not I
automatically assign them a seat or
whether that I will allow them to wait
first and for me to approve them before
I admit them into the group
a fourth way to add people is through
auto log-in and that's an excellent
procedure for large institutions with
thousands of people what that entails is
that you have on your website or an
internet page a link that is coded to
provide a data form behind it so that
when one of your people clicks that link
that person comes on over to the ælis on
your library and a data form is sent
with them and the all then processes
that data it says ok it's a new person
I'll create a new enrollment for that
person and admit them or it's a
returning person you know check to see
whether it has that person needs a seat
or not and give one accordingly and so
everybody comes in in a logon state
transparently with no effort and so it's
a very nice option but I cannot
I can't demonstrate it here so if
someone were interested in that I would
recommend that they contact me later and
we could talk about it I can send them
some information about it so let's go
back to the console now we look about we
look at how we might be managing people
and at the tonker console we have a
table I'd have several columns that are
three columns this first column here to
the left is a summary of the active
seats that I have in the current
subscription well in this test group
I bought 16 seats in the subscription
seven are still available to be assigned
to different people nine have already
been assigned to people who are already
committed and I've lost none to
detachment attachment is when you exit a
member from your group and if a seat has
been used by them that seat goes with
them the central column here the second
column has a summary of my group members
I have a total
ten people in this sandbox group nine of
them have been given a seat and one of
them not and over on the far right in
this column we have a little bit more
information about the people with a seat
this tells me how many have not used
their seat and an unused seat can be
released from a person and given to
another person within the group so it's
not a it's not a commitment until
somebody has actually entered a course
or an exam and then it becomes committed
to the person okay so looking down
further we see some search utilities
this first one is a global search that
if you enter a text string you would
search over name email address same
status as a this column here roll and if
I were to append a or to a place of an
exclamation mark in in front of that
search term then that term would be
excluded from the search results
I can also search on specific fields
user name last name first name or seat
and below that and my headers I can
click on those headers and sort them out
to numerically a disease e2a like so and
I can do that last night first name and
so forth and then I can also click on
training assigned and to see who is not
trained click again see who is trained
by the check mark and on the far right I
have these icons that are dynamically
set to correspond to a person status so
the first icon you'll see is it we see
thumbs down and some of these roads and
probably you don't have any yeah I do
have a thumbs up the thumbs up is to
approve a seat a thumbs down is to
release a see from some of the was not
yet used it and where it's missing that
seat has already been accessed and now
committed to the person and then
sweeping to the right the next icon is
profiling training so I could look up
the person information also a tab for
their transcripts and a tab for their
assignment I can send a password reset
email to that person I could manage
rolls so for example I could on an
individual here I might say Ashley were
bit I could make her a coordinator or
monitor and possibly an author and I
click Submit and that she now has the
labels for those two roles the next icon
is assigned training which help them a
little bit later then a sign authoring
so that if I have custom courses I can
assign to particular individuals which
courses I want them to review and/or
edit and the final icon is to detach a
person or exit them from the group and
you can undo it so we have a way to
bring them back if a mistake was made or
they returned back to your group so
let's talk about the training plans we
can have as many training plans as you
want a training plan is just a
collection of courses that we pull
together and we're going to be signing
to one or more persons over and over and
over and we can call it anything we want
the name is not it's not important
because only coordinators see the name
the people who receive the courses just
see the courses so let's take a look at
what's in this training plan I have some
control over how long they have for a
deadline thirty days from the date that
is assigned or up to one year a
retraining interval which could be never
or up to five years and also a feature
to auto assign a training plan to every
new person that comes into my group or
not I have it turned off now in my
training plan I have these four courses
working with the AIA Cooke common
compliance issues pain management
aseptic technique and under each one I
have choices for the type of activity
exam only of course only or both and you
can see I've selected the same for all
and I could to remove one here and on
the far right I have our avail
courses which I could drill down to and
true
like a drop drag and drop I could add
another course if I wanted to or not
whatever changes would make would want
to make sure we submit so coming back to
the console
I might select now when I turn a row
green like when I have the mouse on that
row that person is selected but I want
to do a hard select I put a check mark
in this box and let's check a few people
so we have four people and I'm going to
go ahead and just click one icon in one
row assigned trainee and all these four
people including myself I will assign
training to yes and I'll choose the
training plan and if I had other
training plan to be listed here
I can also beer off into our list of
courses in assigned individual courses
to any one particular person so I don't
I'm not limited to the batch I can
become flexible so I'll go ahead and
click Submit and now you see all the new
check marks that are here that these
people have that assignment now what it
looks like to a person who's been
assigned I'm going to go ahead and
refresh my screen because the next time
I would to login this is what it would
look like I would have a new button here
called assignments which has a number of
courses that I'm assigned in a little
red circle and we could click that
button and look I had to add at that
course after all so I actually have five
courses here each each title here is a
link to enter the course I also received
information here about what the activity
is I'm supposed to do and the due date
so let's go ahead and enter a course now
if we wanted to do that we could we have
several ways to do that we can put in a
course title like a keyword and search
for a title we can go through our menus
here daos libraries menu or the group's
own
tracks which are their menus I have the
dashboard I have a list of course that
I've been in recently in case I'd like
to click one and resume where I left off
or as we saw today we now have these
assignments so I might take one of these
courses perhaps and here's my start and
so now we're proceeding through the
lesson and there's navigation at the
bottom here to proceed to the next or
prior lesson I also have navigation to
skip around to other lesson and when I'm
ready I can take the exam which would
look like this and so I can you know
scrolling down I can complete the exam
and then submit it for scoring and I
should point out too that on every page
course page or exam there is a comment
field so if I had a question or if I had
a problem that I didn't agree with what
was written perhaps I could enter a
comment and then submit it and that
would be email to a laughs and finally
as group or name we might take a look at
the report and we can perhaps proceed
Christine Christina to take questions
for for anomie yes thank you so much dr.
Duffy now I'd like to remind our
audience how to commit their questions
you could submit questions by typing
them in the Q&A box can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window we
will try to answer as many questions as
we can
now our first question is oh let's see
dr. Turner I might have you answer this
one um we're not in tumors Senden says
the aala s webinars look great
however the live presentations are in
the middle of the night where we live
how can my staff benefit from these
webinars
thank you Christina that's a it's a very
good question and it's one of the
limitations of doing webinars we can't
do them in every time zone or we would
be doing them 24 times a day but what we
can do and what a lot of people really
benefit from the a live webinars they
are recorded and after the live
presentation the site when you signed up
for it you would be sent a link to that
recording and you can listen to them at
any time you want to they're open for at
least 90 days after the webinar so what
a lot of people do is they will gather
their groups and listen to the
recordings and that is a way that you
you don't participate life but you do
get the benefit of the webinar thank you
dr. Turner dr. Joffe how other have you
answered this question
what kind of support does a ALS provide
to users of the ALL well pretty pretty
broad range of support because we
recognize that the people need help
learning how to use a system especially
as group coordinators and authors and we
recommend that new groups or groups that
at some pivotal point in managing their
group contact us to help us talk them
through how to how to do those steps so
we often provide email support telephone
support and we're glad to do that also
for individuals sometimes they have
problems getting their passwords to work
or getting onto the site and we offer
help to them as well and so we check our
emails constantly even on holidays and
weekends and we provide support to
anyone who needs it
thank you dr. Duffy dr. Turner why are
all the AAAS certifications only offered
in English that's a question I get a lot
and the reason they started out is
because we are the American Association
for laboratory animal science although
the certification programs are offered
worldwide and we have certified people I
believe in 38 different countries so it
is widespread and it is in English the
reason that the certifying body
determined was because english is the
language of science now that also leaves
open that there's a lot of people
working in laboratories that language
English is not their native language and
some laboratories will use the
certification study materials to help
the people learn how to converse in
English they will use it to actually
teach English some of them will
transcribe into translate into another
language some of the courses that the
certification and based on however the
exam is in English and the primary
reason for that is psychometrics of the
examination it's part of the intricacies
of offering a certification program is
that you have to make sure that each
exam and each language you offer is
psychometrically sound and once we
offered it in one language we would have
to offer it in any language required
that's part of certification or
requested part a certification law dr.
sonner I had another question come in
that's pertaining to the one you just
answered something how do you answer
this as well they can I translate AAAS
materials from English to another
language yes you can and the way that
you can do that is through a licensing
agreement a less has a contract that we
would require both parties to sign and
there's no fee for doing it as long as
you don't sell the products and then we
would have to look at your translated
product and to make sure that it does
conform with a standard
but if you would like to translate some
of the materials you would need to
contact a lass office and get a copy of
the contract and then execute that
contract because there is you know all
of our materials are copyrighted so you
can't just take them and copy and
translate them without an agreement with
us thank you dr. Turner dr. Tapia if you
would answered this one and it's a
similar question to dr. what I asked dr.
Turner but in regards to the áall
courses have an audience member who
would like to know if they can if the
all courses if they can be translated to
another language they can be because
they all in his programming supports
other languages and we've seen some of
our courses translated or people have
worked in that to some extent I've not
seen a lot of that effort yet but it's
quite possible so our system is fully
supportive of it and it would have to be
a custom course it would be restricted
to that group that did that work but
it's all possible and would be happy to
help them to see how they could do that
that's a few another question for you
what resources are available to help us
learn about managing a group on me all
well actually i would go back to that
that health center that health center
has a lot of articles it's like a wiki
and it's growing all the time as
questions come in and we realize that
hey with not with that described that we
need to we need to add some information
on what the operations are related to
that key word and so it's growing and
it's really I think very
well-established and very helpful we
also have those videos that I mentioned
in the tour and then lastly we find that
group coordinators need to be in touch
with us so we can help them navigate
through the system
it's a very large system and the tour
today
really showed only the highlights so
with the complexities and all and also
the different environments that a group
might have we would we would like for
group coordinators to be in touch with
us to get the help they need thank you
now we are just about out of time so
that will have to conclude our
question-and-answer session but to our
audience members if you have submitted a
question and we did not get to your
question your question will be answered
via email after the presentation I would
like to once again thank dr. Ann Turner
and dr. Nicole Duffy for their
presentation dr. Turner dr. Duffy would
you like to have any um Japanese final
comments for our audience we really this
is Ann and we really appreciate the
opportunity to participate in this
program we would like to invite you to
contact us if you have questions any
either about the education about any of
the other a less programs a less
services or membership in the
organization we really appreciate the
opportunity and and thank you for
organizing it and helping us work
through it yes thank you very much thank
you again dr. Turner and dr. Duffy I
would also like to thank lab roots for
making today's educational webcast
possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
May 9th 2017 you will receive an email
from lab roots alerting you when this
webcast will be available for replay we
invite you to forward that announcement
to your colleagues who may have missed
today's live events we thank you for
joining us and hope to see you next time
goodbye